scp-096 the shy guy versus  scp-055 the unknown object  scp-055 is an anti-mean meaning that  it's impossible to remember any of its  properties after viewing it when matched  up against  scp-096 an anomalous humanoid that  attacks anything that sees its face it's  difficult to say who would come out on  top if scp-055 is alive and placed in a  room with scp-096  the shy guy would charge forward with  murderous intent but as soon as it  blinks or looks away the crazed creature  would forget about what it was running  towards entirely if scp-055 is a mere  object scp-096 would have little  interest in disposing of it and the two  might be able to co-exist in the same  containment chamber peacefully  unfortunately this is a match-up we may  never have a conclusive answer to wait  what was scp-096 fighting again